[Musique]
un fond intox est avec vous Anthony
Saint Léger bonjour une fois n'est pas
coutume on va parler de basketball
américain alors non pas pour évoquer la
Libération à de Britney Reiner qui a été
sur nos écrans toute la journée mais là
on parle de panier en série oui 5 à
dafiler pour être précis à la manœuvre
c'est lui Steven curry la star Steven
curry meneur des Warriors qui va
enchaîner les paniers vous le voyez de
l'autre bout du terrain on est à 25 30
mètres environ avec il faut le
reconnaître une facilité assez
déconcertante d'autant qu'il ne touche
jamais l'arceau regardez c'est beau 30
secondes de vidéo devenue virale en
seulement quelques heures de ce tweet
publier le 5 décembre et qui vous le
voyez accumuler tout de même les prêts
de 30 millions de vues relayez donc ici
par le l'hebdomadaire américain sportif
sports illestrade et qui nous dit ceci
on vient de terminer le tournage avec
Steven curry ce mec ne peut simplement
pas manquer un seul panier reprise une
formation par des médias américains et
internationaux une vidéo qui a créé la
confusion des internautes beaucoup ont
été sceptiques c'est un montage c'est
pas possible je ne peux pas y croire ça
ne peut pas être réel voilà un
échantillon des réactions que ça suscité
robot pour être vrai Anthony à cette
vidéo elle n'est pas authentique et si
talentueux soit-il Steven curry n'est
pas enchaîné cinq paniers dans cette
vidéo il y avait un indice qui pouvait
effectivement nous mettre sur la voie
lorsque l'on reprend le tweet dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure il y a ici
mention d'un compte Harry Phara Roy
aryfara Roy c'est lui que l'on voit ici
un vidéaste spécialisé dans les effets
spéciaux spécialisés dans le sport il
est basé à Los Angeles spécialisé dans
le sport il collabore d'ailleurs avec
beaucoup de sportifs beaucoup d'acteurs
on voit ici sur son compte Instagram la
mention fait de Will Smith
artiste qui n'en est d'ailleurs pas à
son coup d'essai puisque déjà en 2021 il
y a quelques temps il collaborait avec
Tom Brady le célèbre Tom Brady le joueur
de football américain qui dans une vidéo
assez similaire on va la regarder
ensemble elle est ici et bien lui aussi
réalisé une sorte de prouesse finalement
d'envoyer ce ballon trois fois de suite
parfaitement au bon endroit dans ce
robot qui le lui renvoyait
instantanément et il va même à la fin de
la vidéo réussir à faire tomber ce robot
et bien voilà pour la chute c'était
comme on l'expliquait d'ailleurs à
l'époque aux observateurs de France 24
là encore il s'agissait d'une vidéo de
synthèse avec des effets spéciaux et
comme à l'époque d'ailleurs contacté par
France 24 l'artiste n'a pas souhaité
détailler les détails justement donner
les détails de cette vidéo ni le but de
ce de sa manœuvre retour à Stephen Curry
qui fasse à l'ampleur du phénomène et
bien du lui-même un démentir l'authent
possibilité de cette vidéo effectivement
Steven curry qui note toutefois le
compliment qui qui prend ça en tout cas
comme un compliment qu'on ait pu croire
que la vidéo ait été réelle il faut dire
que les faits d'armes du meneur des
Warriors rendent cette vidéo crédible
regardez cette vidéo qui cette fois est
vrai elle date de 2020 on le voit
enchaîné les paniers et pour cause il en
a fait 105 des paniers à 3 points qui
plus est 105 en seulement 5 minutes là
encore sans jamais toucher l'arceau une
vraie vidéo Steven curry qui a
d'ailleurs été consacré par le magazine
Sport illustrate dont on parlait tout à
l'heure athlète de l'année alors
s'agit-il de des informations et bien le
débout est ouvert un deux écoles là où
certaines certains parlent de
désinformation d'autres répondent tout
simplement divertissement en tout cas il
y a eu tromperie ça c'est un contestable
révélateur aussi qu'avec un bon outil de
montage et bien n'importe quelle vidéo
peut devenir crédible la rédaction des
Observateurs de France 24 a interrogé à
cet effet Jean Gabriel Garcia il est à
la Sorbonne il s'intéresse justement à
la question de l'éthique dans le
numérique et nous dit ceci cette vidéo
peut rendre complètement floue la notion
de réalité on ne sait plus ce qui est
vrai de ce qui est faux on ne doit pas
pour autant tomber dans le scepticisme
permanent mais cela est un rappel à une
interrogation permanente pour confronter
et rechercher des sources fiables sur un
contenu vidéo même s'il semble véridique
on ne le dira jamais assez vérifiez
avant de partager merci Anthony
Saint-Léger info intox avec Anthony